da finden jetzt natürlich veranstaltung
statt aus diesem kirchentag wir schalten
wir rüber in die peter hahne
gedächtniskirche in berlin neukölln
super store in wird schneider frau
schneider erst mal vielen dank dass sie
ihren ökumenischen gottesdienst extra
für uns unterbrechen kein problem der
welt allerdings ist es kein ökumenischer
gottesdienst sondern ein ökonomischer
denn unser kirchentag wird ja nicht nur
vom steuerzahler unterstützt sondern in
diesem jahr auch von ganz ganz tollen
sponsoren
dankbar für volkswagen daimler die
drogeriekette dm und den wunderbaren
hersteller von hochdruckreinigern die
firma
mit hochdruck im bereich
machen sie gerade werbung
nein um gottes willen ich verbreite das
wort des herrn
was meinen sie gerne jesus damals die
geldverleiher aus dem tempel die
kernstadt hätte wir planen sogar eine
langfristige zusammenarbeit dann wären
wir die achtung evangelische kirche
welche fragen schweine bin ja nicht bei
den katholen doch liebe gemeinde wir
lesen jetzt auf paulus brief an die
passat fahrer
und es begab sich aber das angebot von
kaiser dobrindt ausgehen dass bei den
abgastests ab sofort beschissen werde
dass sich die balken biegen
hosianna dann hole ich mir einen tiguan
bluemotion tdi sprach petrus am besten
kongo blau mit perleffekt ja
entschuldigung wenn ich dann mal ganz
kurz in die liturgie grätsche aber vw
und daimler als sponsor ist das ihr
ernst bei daimler war gerade
hausdurchsuchung nach vorne machen der
geistige steuerzahler die hälfte und
einen nassen boden vier sondern jahr
noch 12 millionen jetzt vielleicht wäre
wunderbar
sehen sie es doch mal so wir geben
volkswagen und daimler die möglichkeit
sich von ihren sünden reinzuwaschen
reinwaschen
für die feinstaub geschädigte haut ab 40
nur 179 jesus hätte sie gekauft
[Applaus]
ok
schneider ich bin kein biologe ich
glaube exakt wegen sowas ist ja hamas
bei den katholiken ausgetreten der
luther mutter wer kenn ich nicht so
liebe gemeinde wir singen das lied
225 seine liebe aus dem überarbeiteten
gesangbuch
[Musik]
endlich
[Applaus]